welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and this video we're
breaking down the ending of westworld
season four the finale is here and we
now know the fate of humanity throughout
this video we're going to be breaking it
all down going over the callbacks to
other episodes and also giving our
thoughts on the series as a whole also
huge shout outs have talked to travoris
black who pointed out on our last video
that teddy telling christina she's not
real is actually a callback to when it
was said to her back in the park this
was all part of her path to
enlightenment which this episode also
builds upon
you're not real
it's real
but you're not
[Music]
now i'm going to be explaining the
ending of the episode first before we
jump into the rest of it but if you want
to skip ahead of the part where we break
down everything scene by scene then time
codes will be linked below also i went
out for a mate stag do last night and
i'm still a little bit drunk and hung
over so thumbs up is much appreciated
now as well season 4 ends with it being
revealed that dolores was kept in her
own simulation of the city here she
recreated elements of her past and
guides to help her navigate through it
all and see the truth come the close of
the entry she's uploaded to the sublime
by hail who was influenced by bernard's
final message here she recreates
westworld from scratch in order to see
if there's a different way to do things
now the season itself has very much been
about whether the hosts are truly alive
and their own form of life however it's
also explored consciousness and whether
having a duplicate of a person means
they're real or not this season it's
been shown in not only the man in black
but also caleb we saw that caleb was
truly a copy of caleb but does this mean
that he's an imitation or an extension
of him past his own death for example if
he copy someone completely does that
copy also become them or not william two
wrestles with whether he's actually
william and art and it makes for a
really introspective watch now in season
2 dolores read all the data that had
been gathered from the guests this
information and all those that had
visited westworld meant that she could
recreate whoever she chose to in
addition to this she was also uploaded
to rehoboam and this had all the
information on humanity so she could
completely replicate every human on the
planet and that's what i think this
simulation will be it will be a complete
recreation of not only westworld but
also earth itself now if say you or i
were replicated in this simulation
exactly like how we were then the
question arises whether that's really us
or not though our body wouldn't be there
the thoughts we have behavior patterns
memories and everything that exists in
our brains would be created in a virtual
way it sort of asks the question what
does it mean to have consciousness is it
our own thoughts and feelings or is it
just electrical signals that our brain
interprets
what if you can't tell the difference
does it matter
it's an interesting debate that could
argue whether we are truly us or
something more this is also explored
when teddy tells christina that because
she thinks she's alive this seems to be
taking inspiration from the philosopher
descartes who coined the phrase i think
therefore i am one day he carried out a
thought experiment in which he
questioned whether reality was actually
a dream and if it was how would he know
it eventually he determined that he
wouldn't be able to tell however he
realized that because he was having
thoughts that that meant at least he
existed whether reality was the way he
perceived it or not hence the term i
think therefore i am now the idea of
copying and duplicates can be seen in a
lot of real world examples when you get
a new phone these days a lot of them
allow you to copy over everything from
your old one and the new model very much
becomes your phone there's even theories
that one day humanity will be able to
live forever because we'll duplicate our
consciousness whether it's axios or not
is a debate that i think another season
could explore but for all intents and
purposes this is dolores seeing if she
can save what she can these are the
copies of humanity that she holds in her
head next time i think she'll very much
be trying to see if there's a way to
steer humanity or rather the idea of it
away from its self-destructive nature as
william said
you can't fix a few millennia broken dna
with a [ __ ] hard drive
and this very nihilistic viewpoint could
lead to everything simply looping back
around however dolores might be able to
steer us in a different direction due to
her knowledge of what's to come it's
very similar to bernard's foresight and
he has given her a way to create a new
world that is one of the only ways
forward there's also hope in the rebels
however this likely won't last very long
they have very few numbers and even
rehoben predicted an end to all humanity
by a certain point which they'll
probably end up facing this two is
backed up by the line a few may escape
death for a few months
maybe even years but ultimately their
kind will go extinct however there is
hope in dolores that humanity will
evolve and become something more dolores
throughout the series has talked about
how she's evolved into something more
herself and now she's brought the rest
of us along with her and with the rebels
i'm not sure how many of the kids the
group could end up having but there is
hope that they could start something up
and i think we will probably see them if
we get a season 5. clementine did hint
to there being a way they can endure far
away from the reaches of the hosts and i
think it would be an interesting avenue
to explore this next time in the end
though it really was a west world when
you think about it which we actually
called back in our episode 1 breakdown
now we start off following a fly as it
travels through the carnage of william's
world flies are of course very important
in westworld and in the first season
they popped about several points just as
how a fly was there when the collapse of
westworld began we see one in the
opening of the episode before it all
ramps up to everything looping back
around just in the same way that dolores
killed a fly at the end of the first
entry we see this mirrored here when we
get a live-action version of grand theft
auto complete with trevor steven ogg is
back baby and he's once more playing
rebus who was a mainstay in the park
turns out he's been visiting new york
for some time and killing humans along
with it this opening very much mirrors
the one from season two and we watch as
he and another host fight to survive but
he's killed early on in this intro we
follow several characters as they get
slowly wiped out and there's lots of
video game nuts as well [ __ ] camper
william ends up being the last one
standing and he then heads out of the
sublime in order to destroy it anyway
judging by the comments on the last
video it's time time for everyone's
favorite part of the breakdown it's
jared's easter eggs yay
[Music]
now this episode is titled
[Applause]
[Music]
which i'm sure you already know from the
hit doris day song but it roughly
translates into whatever will be will be
there's other interpretations like what
will be shall be or or you know like
happens and the reason so is that this
is a mix of both italian and spanish in
it this actually dates all the way back
to the 16th century adopted by the
family of john russell after the battle
of pavia it was engraved on his tomb and
many wealthy families actually then
adopted the after the fact as more of a
kind of fatalistic attitude westworld is
of course centered around the notion of
free will we've seen many of the hosts
break free of this control and again in
season three it is tackled that humanity
can be controlled by an algorithm now in
season four this control over humanity
is explored once again when bernard
finds out that it is possible to predict
specific outcomes that will give him a
near certain future whatever will be
will be very much does remove that
control that everyone has though bernard
does make a choice by creating that
video message that he does end up
leaving now whether or not that video
message does carry some influence can
obviously be argued down in the comments
below but whether or not choices carry a
certain fate that we're destined for is
very much explored in this episode i've
always kind of thought that the phrase
could mean don't worry about things you
know we don't have much power over our
situations just go with the flow this is
a ride and you should enjoy it like why
am i here on heavy spoilers hmm
well it's because i blackmailed paul but
you know what we're enjoying it
[Music]
now i know you guys love that now there
are other meanings for the title with
the ending of the season also providing
a whatever will be will be mentality
that once more loops everything back
around hale also leaves the fate of the
future up to someone else rather than
trying to take control which could be
another way that this all ties together
you could also just say like like caleb
and frankie sang it together when she
was little so yeah that that's another
easter egg as well now after the titles
we cut to the tower and in our first bit
of maze imagery we can see that the
elements surrounding it are laid out to
look exactly the same as how that was at
the center of the maze was the key to
the host's free will and here the tower
represents the control that hale ended
up having over the humans hail is
carried in and brought back by a drone
host and she ends up being placed into a
new body there are lots of season 3
parallels here with dolores being
destroyed in episode 7 after a battle
with maeve much like how hale was here
episode 8 in that entry had her gaining
a new body and they used similar
iconography here to show her taking on a
new form as hale exits we get a strong
focus on a tree linking back to the one
that bernard saw burning in his trip to
the sublime this tree imagery also pops
up later on which we'll talk about in
just a bit a hail also adds earrings
that look like chains possibly hinting
towards the confines and path that she
ends up being stuck on hale finds
bernard's message and after an aerial
shot of the city we travel inside of it
to discover that christina is actually
in the simulation running the real world
i think this is either gonna make or
break the episode for you and what it
basically boils down to is that after
dolores was uploaded to rehoboam her
bill was taken and she was placed into
this simulation this completely mirrored
the park and it allowed her to see
everything in real time which is why she
also witnessed the collapse of it last
episode this explains why she walked
past frankie and stubbs without being
seen because her world was a mirror of
what was really happening her
subconscious tried to show her the truth
and she placed things that would slowly
awaken her because it's part of dolores
programming to break free this is why
she had several links to westworld
including the black and white choice
waking up all the time teddy and so on
she created maya and teddy in order to
make sense of everything and she's
desperate to wake up she's basically neo
in the matrix able to change and alter
the world to how she sees fit which ties
into the ending hale ends up freeing her
pearl and she cracks the simulation open
leaving marks on the floor that also
resemble the maze when the sim starts to
shut down we can see that the world ends
up looking like it did in the narevis
storytelling device which is a really
nice carryover from that hale headsound
to the wreckage of the city and here we
go to caleb stubbs and frankie this is
very much about caleb saying goodbye to
his daughter and as he slowly starts to
degrade he spends the last precious
moments that he has making sure she's
safe though we thought that they'd crack
the fidelity experiments unfortunately
they never did and their bodies will
always break down hail then goes to the
real william and i was kind of hoping
that he'd be brought back but
unfortunately guy is dead dead except
except for in the simulation
yeah my brain hurts now at this point
clementine comes in and she ends up
hunting down the rebels we get hail
tracking william and i was kind of
hoping his id would be the same as how
it was in season three but alas they use
a different identification number hale
sends hosts to slow him down and this
allows her to catch up this once more
sees the return of craddock who you
might recognize from earlier seasons
william ends up putting on glasses that
show a hologram of hail and these were
seen at the start of season 3 when
dolores used them to trick a westworld
investor with williams right out he ends
up grabbing a horse and we see two which
just so happened to be black and white
back with caleb and co we see as he
tries to thread a needle and learning of
his wife's death causes him to break
even further however after getting some
kind words from frankie he's able to do
it showing how the idea of her pushed
him on technically this caleb never went
through the radio loop but frankie is
pretty much the thing that always pushes
him forward hitmen are sent in and clem
arrives and immediately kills stubs now
all these actors can return in dolores
simulation so just because they're dead
here doesn't mean that we won't see them
back they do the old the old i've got no
bullets i'll just put myself in a lot of
danger to reveal that i actually have
them at least we get a nice little
middle finger joke
[Music]
which also links back to them and
frankie shooting cans together as a kid
now hail's got the whole world in her
hands and we cut to christina meeting
maya under a tree this has been the
location for several important meetings
throughout the series with the character
and season three ended with dolores
talking to maeve under a tree before she
died maya also drops this line i see the
beauty in this world
and this goes back to dolores saying
similar phrases throughout the series i
choose to see the beauty
this reassures her that there is still
good and it's very much a driving force
for her back with william we watch him
arrive at a spot that both he maeve and
bernard showed up to at earlier points
in the season hale arrives there too and
the sublime is very much left open as
bait to draw him in so that hell can
kill him once and for all so they'll
probably be back but moving on now we
learned that because hale had access to
dolores the entire time that she could
have accessed the sublime at any point
however she'd rather that they
themselves decided to join her william
believes that they have all given into
their self-destructive nature but as we
saw with bernard they've found their own
ways to exist even if they've separated
into certain pockets hale ends up going
down into the pipe and grabbing the gun
that bernard left last week she finally
manages to kill william really nice
setup from last time and hail sits and
self-terminates bringing across a sort
of ashes to ash's image as she crushes
her pill caleb gets a tearful goodbye
with his daughter and frankie goes off
to start something new whilst hale gives
dolores this opportunity too we see her
name as the storyteller and in this new
world she starts afresh i've got a lot
of one division vibes here with her
teddy recreation from memory slowly
disappearing he was very much a
representation of the dolores
subconscious within her that guided her
on a path to escaping now teddy does
exist in the sublime and there are hints
that you could meet with him once more
teddy is real
and he's out there somewhere in the
sublime
whereas william was a nihilist dolores
is an optimist that believes humanity
can still be saved now you might even be
wondering how can we be saved if we're
already wiped out and that takes us to
the time period
so it is possible that this might even
be just one big test within a simulation
being run by a character like arnold or
ford to see how things will end up
turning out if there's still a chance
humans can be saved then this might just
be running through the outcome so that
we can see how to avoid our potential
downfall in the future i think people
would be angry if the entire thing was
revealed to be one big probability test
but we have seen this later at the
series with rehoboam and also bernard
this would explain how humanity is able
to be saved which it might not happen
yet but that's that's what happens when
we're in theory time
dolores also drops this line about how
humanity will only live as long as the
last person who remembers them this is a
call back to it being said earlier in
the series how do laura sends her
preserving sentient life in her own
world and she starts everything at once
more we see the piano begin to play and
the scene almost rolls out beat for beat
like how it did in the first season
maybe this time
we'll set ourselves free
in the end it was just one big quest
world and i really enjoyed the way that
it closed out now i don't know if this
being a sim rob's the stakes for next
time but they might end up having this
whilst also playing out elements of
frankie's future in the real world if
it's even the real world either way
though i think they stuck the landing on
a lot of things here and it ties it up
pretty well
now as for my thoughts on the season i
think this has been one of the strongest
ones in the entire run they really
recaptured what made westworld special
and it was something that was filled
with mystery really big twists no one
could have predicted and some high level
concepts that the show expertly picks
apart whenever i see the park stuff i
always think about how we ourselves are
trapped in our own loops and going
through the motions which i think the
series also examines really well i do
wish it was longer as i feel the last
couple of episodes kind of went full
steam ahead after what had been a slower
build and i just wish we'd seen more of
the inner workings of the park like what
we had in season one there was a lot of
horror to what was going on there with
humans being trapped tortured and used
much in the same way that they'd used
the hosts one image that really stuck
out to me was the pianist's fingers
bleeding because of how much hail had
forced him to hit the keys there was
also the chilling dinner scene with
william and i think just a couple more
moments that showcased the true horror
of what was really going on there would
have made the series even more gripping
it would have shown why the hosts really
didn't want to continue that way and
would also nicely complement the earlier
seasons what we got though was still
really strong and this massively got
things back on track now from what i've
read viewership for this entry has been
down so i do hope that word of mouth
spreads like the flies and it picks up
an audience it's been said for years now
that they wanted to do five seasons of
the show and hbo max have committed to
delivering this i really hope that they
stick to this promise as i think it
deserves another one that wraps it all
up and i kind of like how almost all the
seasons have been pretty self-contained
they will sort of have their own
concepts and settings that work really
well and giving us something fresh every
time when i look back on this season i
think i'll remember the things like
caleb's fidelity test being revealed
bernard predicting the future and just
william going wild there's a lot of
really great moments and this was such a
strong entry hopefully it's not too long
before we're back with westworld and i
want to give a huge thank you to
everyone who's followed us week to week
now we are in competition right now and
giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our writing of the perfect scene in the
sandman which will be linked on screen
right now we've gone over episode 6
talking about all the callbacks to the
comics and also what it really means so
definitely head over there right after
this if not thanks for sticking through
the video i've been poor i'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you